so let's get started it's my pleasure to
introduce Jeff clean Jeff will be giving
a guest lecture in in the course Jeff is
a senior research manager at uber AI
Labs and which was formed after uber
acquired a start-up that he helped lead
and before that Jeff was the law and
edith harris associate professor in
computer science at the university of
wyoming one of the things that i think
has been really exciting about Jeff's
work is that it actually has spanned
multiple different subfields of machine
learning and artificial intelligence
ranging from deep learning evolutionary
methods and evolving neural networks as
well as robotics so let's welcome Jeff
hello everyone thank you very very much
to Chelsea for the invitation it's an
honor to be here I'm excited to speak
with you today so today I'm gonna kind
of think really long term about where we
how we might achieve our most ambitious
objectives as an AI research community
but before I begin doing that I want to
tell you about a little bit of work that
my team and my collaborators and I have
done that I won't have time to talk to
you about in case you're interested in
looking it up or in case we have the
opportunity to chat one-on-one sometime
the first thing I want to mention is
that we've done some work on automated
ecological understanding so this is kind
of a nice opportunity for people who
work in the deep learning community to
kind of use our skills to help the world
make you know make the world a much
better place so biologists really want
to understand kind of the animals and
their ecosystems what they're doing how
many of them there are
etcetera to manage endanger populations
combat poaching and just to generally
understand ecosystems and so if you
think about it motion sensor cameras
plus deep learning are kind of a perfect
marriage to help by wildlife biologists
do that and we were able to show in this
paper that it works quite well so I'm
excited to see the future of that a
collaborators and I have also done about
a six paper arc in what we call AI
neuroscience so this is trying to
understand how much do deep neural nets
understand about the images they
classify for example including a lot of
these papers which you might find
interesting
and then the final thing I'll mention is
we've done a lot of work in
reinforcement learning particularly on
the question of how to do intelligent
exploration and reinforcement learning
so we recently put out the go explore
algorithm which solves Montezuma's
Revenge and virtually solves the game of
pitfall
which no prior algorithm had scored
greater than zero on and so I think it's
kind of interesting and important to try
to figure out how can we make these are
all algorithms explore like humans do so
we can make them much more sample
efficient so you can check that out if
you're interested okay so here's the
major main subject of today's talk the
first bit is going to be wildly
speculative I hope you don't mind we're
gonna have some fun thinking about like
how might we get to the really really
far goals that we've set ourselves as a
research community and I want to warn
you that you know this is obviously
because it's so ambitious and so
thinking kind of big picture it's not
grounded yet and a lot of experimental
evidence and it's just a discussion so
even if you completely bump by anything
that I say at that phase of the talk
what it's going to do is it's also going
to provide motivation and context for a
lot of the techniques that I'm going to
tell you about in detail which even if
you disagree with the wild speculation
at the beginning I still think you'll
find interesting from a meta learning
perspective and then we'll go through
those techniques in order so let's begin
with the the big-picture stuff so how
you know we all I think in the back of
our heads are interested in trying to
produce artificial general intelligence
or you might call it human level AI or
at least you're wondering whether or not
that's possible and so I think this is
you know obviously like the most
scientific sorry most ambitious quest in
scientific history and it'll change
everything you know every aspect of our
economy culture it'll revolutionize
science etc so the question is how will
we get all the way there now how are we
making criminal progress this year and
next year but how might we really
achieve this thing then in the back of
our community's head we want to we want
to accomplish and so I think that if you
kind of take a step back and you say
what is the traditional machine learning
community you go to nur ups you go to
iclear you go to ICML what are we doing
as a community and I think that we're
kind of implicitly committed to what I
call the manual path to AI now nobody
ever talks about this this is kind of
like the fish that don't see the water I
think that the community effectively is
saying what we're trying to do is
identify the key building blocks to AI
you know and so if you go and you look
at a paper in any given conference what
does it look like
well they say oh I think that maybe we
need this building block here it doesn't
exist yet so I've been a proposed that
we add it I'm gonna take this existing
building block like a highway network
I'm gonna replace it with a res Network
and I show that that works slightly
better so we're kind of finding all the
pieces or improving the pieces and that
kind of
raises some interesting questions which
is you know how many building blocks are
there that it would be required to build
an actual really complicated powerful
thinking machine you know are there
hundreds are there thousands and like
can we find them all one by one is a
community manually I think that's kind
of an interesting question to consider
but even if you think that we can fight
all those building blocks
we're implicitly committed to some phase
two where we are eventually going to
have to put all these building blocks
together into some giant complicated
Rube Goldberg in thinking machine which
is something that I just think is
something that we should say explicitly
because if this is the path were
committed to we should kind of stare at
it clear-eyed and know how daunting of a
challenge it is and I just want to be
clear that I think this is a really
Herculean task you're talking about
hundreds or thousands of non linearly
interacting complicated parts each of
which took a PhD or at least a paper to
get right to begin with and now they're
all interacting so how would you do that
system and like if it doesn't work how
are you gonna fix it so I'm not saying
that it's impossible but I think it's
really really difficult and we should
know that I also think that it doesn't
really fit our scientific culture very
well because we typically have you know
each of you working in a small team on a
paper every couple of years or in
Chelsea's case you know 16 papers for a
year or more I've lost count but either
way well we don't tend to do is stop and
have like an entire CERN like effort or
Apollo program like effort to put all
these pieces together and that might be
what's required to get all of those
pieces I had on the last slide all
together into one functioning working
machine so I think that if you look at
the overall trend in machine learning
recently there's a clear trend and that
is that hand design pipelines give way
to learn solutions over time once we
have sufficient data and compute okay
and so this we've seen this over and
over and over again when we first try to
solve a problem we typically try to hand
code the whole thing that doesn't work
so we say I'm gonna hand codes part of
the pipeline that I'm gonna sprinkle
sedition learning in and eventually once
we have enough data compute we just
realized we should have learned the
whole thing from the beginning this has
happened with features such as hog and
SIF giving way to deep learning it's
happened with architectures the best
architecture is now and see far and
imagenet are learned they've been
searched for automatically they have not
been designed by humans we're seeing
this with hyper parameters and data
augmentation and increasingly a focus of
this class
we're seeing that hand design learning
algorithms are giving away to learn
learning algorithms and so this trend
suggests an alternate path to our most
ambitious goals as a research community
and that is what I call AI generating
algorithms so the idea here is that we
would learn as much as possible this is
an all-in bet on learning and the idea
is that we would have one algorithm that
we start and it starts off simple with
simple origins and it bootstraps itself
up from simplicity to ultimate ly being
extremely intelligent and have a
complicated AI it's gonna do this by
having an expensive outer loop just like
metal learning that is you know it
requires a lot of compute but on the
inner loop what it does is produce a
very sample efficient learner so which
should be familiar to this class and we
have an existence proof that this can
work which is earth right the very very
dumb computationally inefficient
algorithm of Darwinian evolution
produced you and all of you are
extremely sample efficient learners
inside of your life in the inner loop
which is your lifetime so the question
is can we make a such an algorithm and I
think that if we want to pull this off
then we need progress on three pillars
so cully's the three pillars of AIGA s
the first one is that we need to metal
urn the architectures of the algorithm
then look the neural net architectures
for example the second one is we need to
learn metal urn the learning algorithms
themselves which is the focus of this
class and then the third one which is
not very well talked about and kind of
the least research and the least
understood is automatically generating
effective learning environments so in
this what I want to point out is that
handcrafting each of these things if you
had to like design the architecture the
algorithm and the environments that's
very very slow and it's limited by our
own intelligence in contrast it's better
to learn all of these simultaneously and
let mmm like ml and compute do the heavy
lifting
so in today's talk what I'm going to do
is I'm going to talk about work that
we've been doing in each one of these
pillars in turn quickly I want to
mention a little bit more about AIGA s
and then I'll get back to the metal
learning algorithms themselves so one
thing I do want to point out is AI GA is
like any search algorithm are not a
building block free approach you still
have to decide what your search space is
what your search operators are but the
hypothesis is that the AIG pat AIGA path
has fewer building blocks that need to
be identified versus the thousands or
hundreds that exist in the manual path
and therefore it's gonna be easier to
find them and get them to work together
I also want to admit right out of the
gate that AIG is going to be way more
computationally inefficient it's gonna
require tremendous amounts of compute
but if you look back at the history of
machine learning I think that it's okay
because you know computation speeds up
exponentially and some of the best
algorithms were built long before we had
the compute to take advantage of them
like deep learning for example and the
early research research allowed us to
pounce once the computation was
available I also want to point out this
top bullet which is probably where the
most important research will happen and
that is that efficient abstractions of
whatever it was that produced the
miracle that happened on earth those
will help us shave orders of magnitude
off of the planet size computer that was
required to produce us so that's where
the real interest is so our AIGA is a
faster path to AI than the manual path I
actually think that's very debatable but
I ultimately have concluded after
thinking about this that I do think a a
J's are a faster path to AI but I have
high uncertainty so I do recognize that
either one could win but in terms of the
arguments for why I think it's in line
with this trend in machine learning I
think it scales really well it doesn't
require human genius so I borrowed this
slide from Peter OBO which typically he
only has these two pie charts and I've
added this one over here and the idea is
that we don't have to require you know
identify and combine all these building
blocks so I think one thing that's
interesting especially for an audience
like this which are PhD students mostly
is you know if you want to think about
where you want to spend your time I
would argue that it's really interesting
to spend your time on things like AIGA s
and medal learning because it's kind of
like if you go back in time and ask
yourself 15 years ago would you rather
work on a hog and sift they were the
dominant technique they would looked way
better than neural nets but ultimately
the learning based solution took off and
surpassed and it's been much more
general much more powerful so if I could
go back in time I'd want to work on
their own that's actually I was working
on neural nets around that so that's
already having but you should also if
you had a time machine ok so I do think
the community should reallocate more
effort because even if I'm right that
there's some probability mass on AIGA is
virtually all the probability that's
right now is on the manual approach and
so we should reallocate some of our
effort to this approach so there's more
discussion in this paper here I don't
have time to go deep in
AIGA is today that sound this talk is
about but I discussed at length what
who's gonna win the manual path of the
AI GA path I argue that a ideas are
interesting intrinsically interesting
even if they're not the fastest path to
AI that we really have to be worried
about safety and ethics concerns with
them that are unique to this type of
algorithm and also that this should be
considered its own Grand Challenge of
science so you can check all that out if
you want in the archive paper but now
what I want to do is start telling you
about some meta learning techniques that
get us down this road a little bit so
I'm going to systematically go through
these three pillars so let's start with
the first one which is meta learning the
architectures which also is known as
architecture search so this is a project
called generative teaching networks it's
under review right now at AI clear so
fingers crossed it's with this fantastic
group of collaborators and I really want
to single out Felipe here who has
definitely done all of the heavy lifting
on this project so the idea in general
with architecture searches that
architectures matter a lot if you look
at for example image net a lot of the
beans have been architectures and
therefore we should search for them in
Sutra instead of trying to manually
design them so how might we do that well
a really common approach like an idea
that's at the core of all these na s
methods which stands for neural
architecture search is that you train on
real data for some short amount of time
that gets you an estimate of how good an
architecture is and then you do
something with that estimate you can do
something really simple like just do
random search and take the thing that
you're that look the best or you can do
something really fancy like modeling the
space of searches etc but the point is
that all of them in their core tend to
have this idea of training for a little
while on real data getting estimate
after those you know moderate number of
SGD steps and then you're off to the
races so the question is whether or not
we could speed this up and that's what
we try to do in this project so instead
of training on real data for a moderate
number of steps we're gonna try to train
for just a very very few number of SGD
steps and see if that can perform better
and then we're gonna use few step
accuracy so the accuracy after a few
steps of SGD is an estimate of the
asymptotic performance of the network if
I trained it you know for 600 epochs for
the lot of compute in data so why might
that work well if you think about a
typical training set it might look like
this is the teeny teeny plot you might
have like lots and lots of this kind of
0 and lots and lots of this kind of 0
for example it might be the case that
you could get away with just a few of
these sample
in a few of these samples and if you
intelligently sampled these data points
then you could do better than just
training on all of the data sets because
there might be redundancies and there's
been work that's basically showing that
that in fact does work by sub selecting
real data you can do better but if you
think about how humans learn we don't
always learn a task by doing that task I
don't only learn basketball by playing
basketball in fact sometimes I do drills
which do not exactly resemble the sport
itself for example this basketball drill
is really common you dribble two balls
at once which never ever ever happens in
a basketball game but you can still
learn that way additionally you can
actually watch videos of somebody
playing basketball and learn how to play
that way via observation and you can
also read a book about basketball which
is really crazy because it does sorry it
actually does teach you a lot about the
game which i think is really interesting
because that means that we can generate
different types of data that might speed
up our learning more than the real that
and it doesn't have to look like the
real data so also I want to point out
that over time teaching methods improve
you get better drills better videos and
better books so the question is can we
metal learn to generate training data
that allows us to rapidly learn a new
task and if so that could help speed up
neural architecture search so there has
been work already on this which is
really interesting in this paper that
really blew my mind is this hyper
gradient paper from Maclaurin and 2015
they treat the data as a hyper parameter
of the algorithm differentiate back
through all of us you need to the pixels
of the images for M nest and then it
learns what data it should produce to
end up having a learner that trains on
that data do well on M nest they only
generate it they only learn ten samples
and these are the ten samples and as you
can see they look like kind of platonic
digits and then this paper here did that
with a hundred samples so one of the
things that we wondered in this paper is
instead of data generating data pixel by
pixel which kind of leaves a lot on the
table in terms of learning regularities
about the data of themselves and about
the search space etc our idea is that we
were going to learn a generator to
generate data to accelerate this process
and we call that a generative teaching
Network so here's the general method
GTN is going to generate data which a
new had never seen before learning
neural net which is a new architecture
and new initialization will train on the
synthetic data produced by the GTN and
then we're going to optimize the GTN
with meta learning to produce good data
such that that learner performs well on
the target task after a very few number
of SGD steps so here it is in picture
form we have the inner loop you could
generate a noise vector z you pass that
into the generator it produces data this
look big batch of data the learner
iterates over a few steps of SGD maybe
32 for example gets its final weights
pass that out to the work to evaluate on
real data such as m Nastasia see how
well it does differentiate back through
that entire process like mammal for
example and get back to the original way
to the generator and change the weights
of the generator to generate better data
then throw the learner out and repeat
the process over and over it again that
make sense okay so a couple things to do
there's only a few number of steps here
so you're implicitly incentivizing this
generator to train the to create data
that enables rapid learning by the
learner and another thing is that we're
also going to meddle learn the inner
loop hyper parameters like if it's got
like a momentum for example in SGD and
we're going to do that for both the
controls and the GTN to have it be a
fair playing field all right so our
domains are going to be M nest and C far
because this is really computationally
expensive so the first thing we ran into
when we tried this is that it's very
unstable so this is what would happen
when we tried to train and then Philippe
came up with a really good idea which
was to take this idea from Salomon's and
Kingma which is weight normalization and
just reaper amortize the weight vector W
into a V vector normalized and then buy
multiplied by a scalar G and then we
learned both the weight vector and that
scalar and that dramatically improves
the stability of meta-learning
so to show you that here these are
different hyper parameters of the
algorithm without weight normalization
and with weight normalization so before
we did this we were having a lot of
triumph don't spend a lot of time in
compute trying to find the hyper
parameters that make this thing work and
then after we did this it was just
trivial for everything just kind of
worked
so we as a sidenote hypothesize that
this might be a good trick for all metal
learning we're gonna try to do a whole
paper just on that but if you're you
know if your project is not working I
recommend you try this one line code
change here it might really really help
here is a look at the performance
difference between weight norm and not
this was the unstable one and this is
the performance curve with weight
normalization so now that you see that I
just want to stop and say it worked like
we didn't know we started this with then
I would be possible to generate data a
learner could consume and then do well
on real data when the learner has never
seen in real data but it turns out it
does work so this is performance with
the GTN it gets about you know 97.5% on
em nest so my question to you is what
are the samples look like what do you
think I think they look realistic or
unrealistic unrealistic we have one
brave soul who's willing to speak up
here's what the samples look like I
would mostly agree with you hey I mean
you can tell that their digits you can
tell this is M&S but they look pretty
alien and weird which i think is quite
surprising but the interesting thing is
you can train a network on these digits
and then it can do just fine on real
amnesty jets which is kind of crazy some
of them look really pretty recognizable
like this three here and some of them
are totally alien like this four there
and so the idea that unrecognizable
images can meaningly effect neural
networks is reminiscent of this finding
we had in our paper from 2015 deep
neural Nets are easily fooled which i
think is quite interesting and we have
lots of hypotheses for why these GTN
samples are unrecognizable so if you're
interested in that you can ask me that
in the Q and the Q&A at the end of the
talk but we're still kind of speculative
so I didn't put it in the core of the
talk alright so the next thing we notice
is that instead of randomly sampling
this Z code here we can do even better
because if you really want to teach
somebody fast you shouldn't just give
them random data you should teach them
with a curriculum so we said what we can
do is you can cross off the noise
generator and we can put a put a learned
tensor here so now what we're gonna do
is we're gonna just learn the block of Z
codes it's a fixed block that we're
gonna use throughout training and it's
you know the Z code is this length by
the batch size and then this is the
number of inner loop
that's that you do and then you learn
each one of those numbers and pass that
in to the network so we found that that
greatly boosted performance here is your
learning curriculum versus your know
curriculum right here and so from here
on out all of the results am in a show
are with the curriculum version of GT NS
okay so here's the first like really
really kind of fun comparison of real
data to synthetic data what you find is
that if you only have 32 steps of SGD it
is way faster to train on GT n produced
metal learned synthetic data than it is
to just take real data and train on it
so real data is this blue curve here so
my first pop quiz to the class why is
that line going up it's just real data
why does it go up over time anybody yes
yes thank you I was gonna call on you
first yes that's right remember we're
learning the hyper parameters of the
real data algorithm too so it's getting
a better SGD momentum and things like
that over time yes yes yes that's right
and in fact what we'll see later as we
can do even farther than that I think we
got up to 128 and maybe Philippe
Philippe is amazing he was able to push
it even farther than that I believe but
those results are not in this paper all
right cool so the blue curve is real
data eventually gets as good hyper
parameters and it's stuck this is data
steady solution 100 samples directly
pixel-by-pixel learned and this is when
you have a generator which can take
advantage of all sorts of regularities
across examples decom priors etc etc
that's this is outer loop training so
this is meta learning this is inner loop
training it took a little bit noisy but
this is real data and this is the the
GTN data and what we basically found is
that it is faster to Train than this
data so what we wanted them to do is go
back to the original motivation which is
neural architecture search and say can
we use this synthetic data to more
rapidly figure out what architectures
are good in the search space and so
we're going to do this in C far because
that is the standard NES benchmark that
everybody has been working on and if you
look at C far the story is basically the
same
with em nest this is real data over time
and this is GTN over time and you can
see that it performs way better and then
this is I was out of loop on the inner
loop you can see that in you can
basically get the final performance out
of real data at 128 iterations four
times faster with GTN or for the same
budget you can go to a better
performance and so this is way faster to
to learn on now like with M this the
samples here are pretty weird pretty
unrecognizable and pretty alien I mean
you can kind of tell that C far if
you've been looking at C far images for
way too long which I have but yeah you
can't really recognize what any of these
things our versus real c4 images but yet
if you trade on these you end up
performing really well so now the
ultimate thing that matters in
architecture search is not the actual
performance of your learner after
learning because we don't care about it
the real performance after 128 sets what
we care is if the estimated performance
after we do the 128 steps of SGD by the
way that's the 128 I don't know if you
noticed it but the CFR ones go for 128
so even longer anyway the what you care
about is after 128 then we think this
architecture is pretty good or pretty
bad does that actually correlate with
the true asymptotic performance if I
take that same architecture and I train
it forever on real c4 data or whatever
my domain is and what we found is that
there is actually a pretty good
correlation so the top 50% of GTN
architectures so the architectures that
GTN thinks are the best tend to also be
the best when you train them much much
much longer on real data and in fact in
the the top 50% that correlation is 0.56
and if you take the top 10 GTN
architectures there are basically also a
lot of them are in the top 10 of true
performance so it doesn't matter that
you picked this one which isn't actually
good because you also pick this one
which is good so as long as you get
enough of those you're fine and so also
what we found is that you can get as
good of a rank correlation with the fake
synthetic data as training on real data
for in 128 steps of the GTN versus 1,200
steps on real data so to get the same
rank correlation you can either spend
128 fake data steps or 1200 real data
steps which means that GTN is 9x faster
giving you that
meted performance for that new
architecture that you've never trained
before so that's pretty exciting and
what that allowed us to do is basically
produce something that is competitive
with the state of the art for neural
architecture search so what we because
GTN is a drop-in replacement for real
data we didn't do this with really fancy
neural architecture search algorithms
because this are often really expensive
we just took random search we either did
it with real data or fake data and then
we added some tricks that people use and
basically what you find in every paper
and machine learning is that our method
is bolded because it works but what this
is pretty cool is what it means is that
you know in just a few GPU days you can
basically find something that's near
state-of-the-art and see far computation
when using this sort of tricks and
what's also interesting is that there
are other neural architecture search
algorithms like I mentioned that do more
fancy things but that their innovations
are orthogonal to using fake data versus
real data so you can hybridize this GTN
technique with them and that would
perform even better we haven't done that
yet because we're not Naas experts but
we think that's an interesting direction
for future work so the next thing I want
to point out which is really provocative
but also fair warning its preliminary is
that this idea should work really really
well for reinforcement learning not a
lot of people do architecture search on
reinforcement learning but I think that
will change if you think back to the
AIGA paradigm so here's Pohl balancing
which is admittedly very simple and what
you see here this is a to see over time
and this is the performance up to that
environment step the blue line here is
taking a new neural net at every single
iteration here a new neural net and
doing one step of SGD with synthetic
data which means that this red line
point here took a hundred thousand steps
and this blue line point here it took a
hundred thousand steps to Train out the
GTN but at that point I can zap in the
knowledge of how to do pole balancing
into that new neural network in one SUV
sep so if I stopped and launch
architecture search right there with a
whole lot of caveats like does it does
it actually as a predictive you know
outer distribution on new architectures
etc that's a hundred thousand times
faster now I don't expect that to hold
up on a much harder problem but the same
ideas that worked in supervised learning
might also work here in RL and actually
I would argue that they're probably
gonna work even better why because in RL
the hard part is exploration but once
you've learned how to solve the problem
you can teach the next network how to
solve that problem really really fast
and see how good it is at least uh
performing the problem which is a little
bit of a subtly different question for
whether I was good at learning the
problem so it depends on what you want
that architecture search for but anyway
I thought that was interesting
all right so this is a conclusion of the
first mini talk within this talk or the
second one if you count a agas and this
is a for GT n so GT ends produced
synthetic data that trains neural nets
faster than real data it generalizes to
new architectures which is never seen
before it enabled I should have said by
the way when we train the Zhu TM we
train on the distribution of
architectures but then what we tested it
we tested out in wildly different
architectures because the neural
architecture search goes really far away
from that initial distribution and we
found that correlation works quite well
even on those totally different
architectures it enables you to rapidly
estimate the performance of any
architectures and we think this is a
really generic approach it could work
with supervised learning unsupervised
learning semi-supervised learning and RL
and we mostly focused on this and then
should you a little preliminary result
RL it also produced a state-of-the-art
competitive an architecture search
algorithm but through a totally
different means which is like an
exciting new tool to have in the toolbox
for a neural architecture search cool
all right so that is the first pillar
meta learned architectures now we're
gonna get into the home turf of this
class which is meta learning and so the
way that I see the world and I hope this
doesn't conflict too much with Chelsey's
summary of the field from the other
lectures is that there are kind of two
large camps of meta learning one of them
I think is that you metal learn good
initial weights and then you hand it
over to SGD and you let it let it go and
I would say that's kind of the mammal
style that Chelsea is pioneering and
then I would say the other camp is this
kind of idea that you're just gonna
med-alert a recurrent neural network and
it itself is going to invent its own
learning algorithm within it's not going
to use SGD at inference time it's just
going to use the activations within the
network to kind of create its own
learning algorithm this is the learning
to reinforcement learn weighing paper
and also the RL squared paper they come
out at the same time from Rocky duan and
those at open AI I think they're both
awesome both really interesting you'll
see work in this talk on both of them
but I like to give that high level
picture and so let's just
quickly focus on the second camp I know
you know the first camp very well I
probably know both of them but this is
the lrl camp so in the outer loop you
optimize a recurrent neural net with
parameters theta for lifetime
performance so you take this neural net
you deploy it in a world say like
montezuma's revenge you let it play you
see how well it does and then either you
differentiate back to the original
parameters of theta so you the next time
you deploy that net it's a little bit
better or you could do like an
evolutionary algorithm and just you know
mutate the parameters and see if it does
better at cetera etcetera so you have
the outer loop thing optimizing that
initial neural net and then you deploy
it and there's no SGD going on within
its lifetime if you know I like that
metaphor of a lifetime
it does get the reward as an input so it
can actually implement its own
reinforcement learning algorithm now our
ends are Turing complete so in theory
this thing can implement any learning
algorithm that's out there which is kind
of exciting and what was nice is that in
this paper here they show that it learns
on its own in RL to exploit and explore
and exploit which is kind of cool so you
put it in this maze here it doesn't know
where the reward is it explores over
here then over here then over here then
over here and once it finds the reward
it changes the activations within its
own network just stamp in that knowledge
is to learn where to go and then it goes
back there over and over again which are
all these blue dots here and you can see
a vastly outperformed see a three-c
which doesn't have that capability they
also show which is really interesting
that it kind of events may be its own
model-based RL algorithm within its
activations and they have some arguments
in here but there are also some caveat
so I encourage you to go check it out
but I think it's provocative so the
thing that I'm gonna put out there for
this talk is some new work that's
pushing this direction is well it's
great to think about an RNN is
turing-complete often times just being
turing-complete isn't enough you know
we're not going to actually search for
AGI in the space of Turing machines it's
a very inefficient representation to
have your program running so the idea
here is that materials matter you still
have to choose those building blocks
when you go to do metal learning and so
you know L RL RL squared those recurrent
neural networks they have to learn
everything within their activations
that's not how you learn in your life if
you learn something in this class for
example it is not just looping around in
the firing of your neuro
that's what happens if I give you like
my telephone number you have to remember
it for a couple seconds but if you
remember something from anything longer
than about that it's going into the
weights of your brain not on the
activations of your brain and so one of
the things we could do is we could try
to get learning to happen within the
weights of the neural net not just its
activations so the first paper in this
arc here is differentiable hebbian
learning this is work that's done by
myself Thomas Mahoney and Ken Stanley
and I really want to highlight Thomas
here who's really been pioneering this
direction both on this paper and the
next paper I'm going to tell you about
he's a fantastic scientist so the idea
here is that we're gonna deal with heavy
and learning how many of you are
familiar with heavy and learning the 40%
okay so the idea in hebbian learning is
that you can store information and the
weights of the network in addition to
the activations you can all get to use
both but what's different about this
work than anything you've ever heard of
before is that we're going to Train the
heavy and learning with SGD so we're
gonna be able to take advantage of that
very powerful tool to sculpt very
carefully tune heavy and parameters so
just like l r l /r l squared we're gonna
have a recurrent neural network that's
going to be deployed at inference time
and it's going to have no SGD inside it
but now it's going to be able to use
heavy and learning to do some of it not
just like change its own activations so
the one slide summary of heavy and
learning is that neurons that fire
together wire together you've probably
heard that phrase is how its quickly
usually described so here's how it works
the new weight in the network the so the
weten the network the weight between I
and J at time t plus 1 equals the old
weight plus a little bit this is just a
learning parameter learning rate
parameter of the output of the post and
presynaptic neuron firings so if the
neurons both fire in the same direction
both positive or both negative you get a
positive value the weight increases if
they both if they fire in the opposite
way so one fired positive in one part
negatively you get a negative value and
the weight decreases and so this will
kind of reinforce themselves now that
might sound like it's hopeless and it
will never do anything interesting but
in fact people for a long time I've been
showing that this kind of unsupervised
learning rule can do lots of really
powerful unsupervised learning including
like pca and associated a recall where
you give a few numbers of
a few digits of a foeman number and then
it will return like the full phone
number you go to a few notes of a song
and like the whole rest of the song
comes back and this is happening in your
brain neuro scientist has been showing
for a long time so what we're gonna do
here is we're gonna do differentiable
heavy and learning and so the idea is
that we're gonna set up hebbs rule
instead of a neuron that and then we're
gonna let SGD sculpt its parameters so
here's how this works you take a
recurrent we're going to call it a
plastic Network because the weights
themselves can change we're gonna train
it end to end with gradients so in the
inner loop the network ends up updating
with no SGD it's just kind of going
through its own motions and updating
itself according to these heavy and
learning rules and then in the outer
loop we're gonna differentiate through
the entire episode to update the
trainable parameters with SGD this is a
little confusing because we're using SGD
in the outer loop but not on the inner
loop so here's how it works
the output of any given neuron is going
to be a nonlinear non-linearity and then
your typical weighted sum where you have
but now the weights here we're typically
the typical weighted sum where you have
a weight which is the whole parentheses
here times the incoming activation but
what you have is a fixed part so this is
the normally kind of like a normal
weight this is just learned by SGD and
then you have this plastic part so
inside the lifetime of the organism this
component of the weight will change and
then this gets added to this and so the
weight over time can change that makes
sense so this alpha here is a term that
allows each weight to have a different
ratio of the fixed part and the plastic
part so SGD can choose these weights
over here
we always need them to be set to these
value so just crank alpha to zero and
we'll only use the green part of the
weight these other weights here can be a
mixture of both and these weights over
here can be like entirely plastic and
have no fixed component whatsoever and
everything in between
so sqt gets control alpha in this case
and then what is alpha being multiplied
by it well we call this the heavy and
trace here this H this is a purely
lifetime quality of quantity it's
initialized to zero every time and then
the way that it works is that the new
heavy and trace is just equal to a fret
like the old heavy and trace a bit of
and then also a bit of whether or not
the neurons fired together so should it
wire together that will make sense
cool so what we found on a variety of
experience is that this works remarkably
well and often really does better than
LS TMS and an otherwise non plastic
recurrent networks so on this task here
on Omniglot at the time this was tied
for state of the art with Chelsea here
here you go and some other papers and
basically it does about as well but uses
this totally different method which we
think is really interesting you can also
take this neural net here and you can
take this really simple like kind of
associative recall pattern recognizing
thing so you might give it a series of
patterns here and then you give it a
partial pattern and it's job is to fill
in what it saw so this is kind of like
I'll give you a bunch of phone numbers
I'll give you a few digits from one of
the phone numbers that you saw and you
have to give me the rest of that
particular phone number and what we show
there is that an LST our sorry a
non-plastic recurrent neural net which
does not perform very well on this task
LST m's actually ultimately performed
well but look how much faster they happy
network learns this task so there's a
pretty dramatic difference there and
then we went to a much harder version of
this and we said alright we're gonna
give the network up series of images
this is now a pretty high dimensional
search space we're going to flash these
images and then we'll flash it half of
one of the images and it has to fill in
the rest of that image and has to be
able to do that with an image that's
never seen before so this is a lot of
high density information storage right
you get shown like a couple images and
then you have to remember every pixel
from every one of those so you can
reconstruct it when you only see half of
it storing all of that information in
your activations might be very hard but
the hebbian learning makes it easier
because you can use the weights to do it
sorry
so I don't have a plot here else teams
couldn't even solve it and our network
actually does quite well and solving
that and then that's with two million
parameters which is kind of interesting
because in the history of a heavy and
learning it's always tiny little neural
nets and so now we're able to scale
hebbian learning up to two million plus
parameters which is kind of a new era
for heavy and learning which is pretty
interesting so the next task that we
have here is maze navigation and so this
is kind of cool because it learns again
on its own to explore and exploit so you
drop an agent which is this
yellow thing here in this maze it can
only see its local neighborhood it has
no idea where it is and what it's
supposed to do what it eventually
figures out over meta optimization is
like oh I see you want me to explore
this maze and then the second I get to
the green thing you want me to go back
to it as many times as possible that's
the reward function so the initial
random network you see here just kind of
bops around and does nothing as you
would expect but then look with this
thing what it basically I don't yes the
first time it has to explore until it
finds this green thing and then it just
shoots right back to it every single
time
so it's remembered that a zit rose how
to explore that maze it knows how to
find the treasure and then it knows how
to return to it over and over and over
again which is pretty cool so this is
learning to reinforcement learn /r l
squared down here this black curve no
sorry the non-plastic one red and what
you see this is what like a normal l s
TM does for example and then if you just
have uniform plasticity so you don't get
to learn a per weight alpha but just one
alpha for the whole network
it also doesn't work it's only once you
give the degree of freedom to SGD to
have that per wait alpha within the
network that i can do much much better
on this task which i think is pretty
interesting ok any questions about that
yeah there's one right there I am now
forgetting whether it saw them all at
training I think I'm pretty sure that it
a test time we show in new images and
can do this task yeah
virtually sure that we would have done
that but I'd have to check the paper
it's been a little while since I read it
cool yeah
yeah I think that's a fair thing to
think about I mean there's obviously you
could store information in activations
you can store it kind of to disk in the
differentiable storage and you can store
it to weights and I think there's gonna
be pros and cons to the different
approaches but I both I think is kind of
attention with the differentiable
plasticity is that the weights are a
part of the kind of the computation and
so neck has pros and cons like in the
the dnc style stuff you kind of write it
to disk and then it becomes like the
input to this program whereas in the
heavy in case you kind of get to change
the program on-the-fly and so it's very
hand wavy but I think in some situations
one's going to be easier than the other
and I don't think we know yet really
where like which type of problem one
shines on versus another I think you
could get a DNC to do the image
completion task for example but my guess
is that there are gonna be other types
of tasks so you really kind of want to
bend the program in different ways
temporarily that it's gonna be hard to
mould the DNC to have like a generic
function that takes different inputs and
does wildly different things as opposed
to kind of changing a few ways to change
the program it's just my instincts but
that's a really interesting area of work
is to compare these different approaches
to storing information great those are
good questions okay
I'll push on so the next thing that we
wanted to look at was a subject that's
near and dear to my heart I've worked on
this in my lab Wyoming on smaller neural
networks and now we're getting to see at
scale and that's the idea of
neuromodulation
and so here the idea is that this comes
from another paper that was led by
Thomas it's also they deteriorate while
now but Thomas did the heavy lifting
here and so the idea here is were going
to do differentiable neuro modulated
hebbian plasticity so it's taking it one
step further and the idea is that have
you
is very local if the you know every
little connection is kind of getting
updated according to the data that's
flying through it's a very difficult
optimization process to kind of harness
and and heard and so what you might want
is that you want learning in a set of
like a certain subset of the weights
only in certain situations like maybe
once I've learned to solve the problem I
want like all the ways to just stay put
and not do anything I don't want the
heavy and bouncing around and so I want
to like freeze learning but then if
something happens that I might want to
like crank learning up but I might not
want to pick it up everywhere I might
want to crank it only up in the part of
the network that was responsible for the
task I was just solving for example so
that's the idea behind a neuromodulation
in neuromodulation you can have one
neuron on the network like this one here
inhibit learning in another part of the
network and so it can like basically you
could say for example if I'm playing
chess that only turn learning on on the
chess playing part of the network and
turn it off everywhere else so I don't
overwrite information in other parts of
the network that's kind of a cartoon
example so how do we pull that off in
practice well we do this differentiable
neural modulated plasticity or we call
it backprop Amin Thomas came up with
that and the idea is we're going to have
the same heavy in formulation the
notation is slightly different but it's
basically the same idea as before but
the new part is now the new heavy and
trace is the old hebbian trace plus
whether the neurons fired together or
not multiplied by the output of some
other neuron M and that other neuron can
be an entirely a learned function of
data so that could be the thing that
tells you whether you're playing chess
or not or are you doing or tells you
whether or not reward just went way up
or way down or some other complicated
function of the data now in addition to
doing that which is pretty interesting
there's also in the paper and
eligibility trace version so what that
says is don't just turn learning on and
off in certain contexts but store
information about which neurons were
involved in what situation but don't do
anything with that just store it and
then if something happens later like in
a hundred steps like I had a really big
reward or a really big prediction error
then go back and change the neurons that
were involved in a certain way so if you
read the southern Bartow book there's a
lot of work on eligibility traces in RL
which is pretty interesting so here's an
eligibility trace version of
differentiable plasticity so in a
nutshell this works even better than
differentiable hebbian plasticity at
least on the prot some problems so on a
simple task here where we were trying
- basically recognize whether or not a
certain symbol have been given to us a
couple times steps ago then what you see
is that the heavy differentiable hebbian
plasticity which is the green and the
non plastic networks at all don't solve
that problem at all and both the
Eligibility trace version which is we're
calling retroactive and the simple
differentiable hebbian neuromodulation
version which is kind of a normal back
prop Amin both of those solve that
problem very well and then here on this
maze task they both solve this problem
way better than non modulated plasticity
which is not even on the charts on this
Oh actually noticed here in blue and
then same thing down here on this penn
treebank problem cool so the final thing
that I want to show you well I just
asked there's any questions on that so I
think it's pretty cool now you know
something's wildly different than SGD
that's controlling the the neuron the
neural network at inference time and it
can turn learning on and off of
particular connections and in different
contexts in different connections it's
just a lot of extra degrees of freedom
for meddler okay so the next thing I
want to talk about this is unpublished
work I don't we've never presented this
outside of DARPA meetings so you're the
first people to see it this is a project
that I'm very interested in which is
trying to learn to continuously learn
this is done with this fantastic team
here and I really want to call out Sean
who is done the lead author and has had
come up with a lot of the innovations on
the projects so in my opinion one of the
Achilles heels of all of machine
learning is catastrophic forgetting how
many of you are familiar with this term
know everybody that's really good good
okay so then I will just do this briefly
because I know at least we're putting it
on YouTube the idea is that when you're
sequentially learning a task you first
learn task a then you learn task B and
what you do is typically machine
learning models whether learning B they
have no incentive to hold on to any of
the information for a so that is
overwrite everything they knew about a
and it corrupts a and then they lose the
skill for a right that's your classic
catastrophic forgetting now animals
including yourself don't do this you're
able to like you know study for this
class to go to some other class and
study for that and then go like play
badminton
we played in ten years and just pick up
where you left off without corrupting
your knowledge for all of these classes
and through our lives we get better and
better at a variety of tasks and if we
forget what happens gradually not
catastrophic ly which is what happens in
machine learning models so I think we
have to solve this if we want to make
major progress in AI I think it's kind
of embarrassing how little progress
we've made actually on this problem but
that's not for want of trying we've been
working on this problem probably problem
for very very long and there's a lot of
early work that was really interesting
that had all these different kinds of
techniques but one thing that unifies
them in my opinion is they're all kind
of manually designed this is like the
manual path to AI like I think I know
how to solve catastrophic forgetting
what I need are sudo rehearsal patterns
or I need to have sparse representations
so I'm gonna have an auxilary loss for
that etc etc there's been recent work
that I loved also but I would also put
it into the camp of stuff that's
manually designed so II W C which is a
wonderful paper it's still kind of a
hand design technique I think I know how
to solve this problem let's use some
really cool math and Fisher information
and we're going to try to solve it same
with progressive Nets and there's been
more and more and more and more and it's
all kind of manually designed but you
know my proposal or aren't they a
proposal that kind of comes from the
AIGA perspective is like let's not try
to figure out how to solve this
ourselves let's just set the problem up
like ask machine learning to figure out
how to solve the problem which is to say
let's learn to continuously learn and
meddle learn the solution so my
hypothesis is that we're not smart
enough to build systems that can
continually learn so let's do the AIGA
thing and you know that is in contrast
in the manual path which might say we
might want sparse representations so
let's kind of like create an auxilary
loss train for that and hope that that
works so I like better learning because
you just get to kind of ask the system
to produce what you ultimately want so
going back to these two camps of
learning now we're going to flip to the
other one that's more like the manual
school of metal learning here to use
that so I know that you're all very very
familiar with this kind of metal
learning and inner loop learning but I'm
gonna introduce you to some of the
terminology that I'm gonna use because
this talk this part gets really
complicated so I don't want to lose you
so the general gist is that you know
with the typical Memo approach you start
with your parameter vector here and then
within one inner loop of training you
copy it you start doing inner loop
steps and then at the end of all of that
you evaluated on your medal loss and you
differentiate back to that entire block
to the original parameter vector you
take a gradient step and then you repeat
the process right standard for this
group so I want to introduce some terms
I think you use these terms I think I've
heard you and Sergei use these terms so
I like that we're maybe starting to
create some standards in the community
so we call this whole process meta
training and then in particular I don't
know if you use these terms or you do
good okay so you this will be old news
for you but we had to like kind of
basically really commit to using these
amongst our team or we were just
constantly talking past each other this
probably is happening in your class
projects so we call this meta training
trading data whatever it's training on
in here so meta training training data
and then the stuff that you evaluate
here we call medic training test data
you could also call this meta training
validation data at your preference but
I'm gonna call it test for symmetry and
so it's good to keep that in your head
and then what you do is that there was
after meta training you have your final
initial parameter vector theta M here
you now pull that over for meta testing
and now you might want to test it on
totally different data that it's never
seen before right so now you have meta
testing training data which is a bit
mine bindi but once you get used to this
language it really helped clarify things
right so the this network here has never
seen this training data so it's meta
testing training data it does all that
but then you still want to test this
learner on something that's never seen
so you can't test it on this stuff so
now you have to go over here to meta
testing testing data that all make sense
good glad you got it okay so with all
that language in mind now I'm gonna make
it a little bit more complicated because
we want to do continual learning it
can't just be ID chunks of data right it
has to be sequential data so now we're
gonna do that all of that but we're
gonna do it in tasks in a row so you
have task 1 task to task you know T and
then your meta loss here because now you
want to say how much did you remember
not just the most recent thing you heard
so you train down but all of it now you
have this you know your metal loss is
going to be on all of the tasks that it
saw so make sense and then you do all of
that
and that's that's the general framework
cool so a couple actually at ICML Martha
white gave a talk that I thought was
really eye-opening so basically we had
been working on this vision of trying to
learn to continuously learn for a really
long time and it wasn't working very
well and then she basically put out an
algorithm that did exactly that and did
it really well and it was called
originally MRC L for metal learned
representations for continual learning
but they changed the name recently in an
updated version of the paper to O ml and
in our opinion that's really validated
this vision that you could learn to
continuously learn so we kind of chose
to scrap what we what we were doing and
build on top of their algorithm so
here's how a ml works it does pretty
well so what they do is they meta learn
a representation chunk here this red
part of the network over across meta
learning outer loop op iterations and
then of the inner loop they're only
going to learn this blue these kind of
inference layers here so they call these
the tln and so that after meta training
when they go to meta test they'll freeze
this red block here and they'll only
train in these blue layers here okay and
what they show is that this performs
really well like historically
catastrophic forgetting you learn one
task you learn a second task in you're
hosed
they were showing now that after a
hundred and fifty classes
sequentially trained on Omniglot where
each task is one class of Omniglot you
could still do pretty well which was
just kind of for me kind of mind-blowing
that you could solve catastrophic
forgetting across 150 tasks so you get
on medic test training so the stuff you
already saw you could remember 97% we
see of near-perfect memorization even on
the first you can still remember the
first class after seeing the hundred and
fiftieth class which is pretty cool of
the stuff you actually saw now when you
go to generalize so different instances
of either the first class or the 150th
class you know you're generalizing it's
much worse it's like 63 percent which is
still way way better than chance and way
better than anything that came before
that I am aware of what's also really
cool is that it learned on its own that
sparse representations were are a very
good idea which is cool so here is for
example a method that was explicitly
trying to design sparse representations
and you can see they're pretty sparse
these are different instances
the training example and this is uh
Navarrete across the whole dataset but
many of the neurons were dead it just
learned to never use most neurons if you
just do normal deep learning what you
get are pretty highly active non sparse
representations but if you look at
miracle it learned to be sparse but also
you learn to use all of its neurons in
its representation which is pretty
powerful
so neuro ml gets a lot right that stands
for online I think it's online aware
meta learning maybe I forget that
acronym
anyway it's it's a lot right but it's
ultimately still subject to SGD because
it's training that red block and then it
just hopes inference time and met a test
test I'm sorry a meta test training time
that SGD is not going to look kind of
mess up the weights a film that network
so the question is could we do better
could we try to allow more control to
optimize the SGD - or at least modify
the SGD so that it can basically not
cannibalize its own information while
it's learning at meta test time and so
what we propose is a different type of
kind of version of this which is based
on neuromodulation so we're going to now
we're gonna allow a neuromodulation and
modulate SGD but this is a different
type of neuromodulation than what i was
just telling you about instead of
directly gating the plasticity turning
learning on and off of the network it's
going to gate the activations of the
network okay and so if you gate the
activations of the network we call that
selective activation that also
indirectly allows you to control
learning which we call selective
plasticity so it's a lot easier to see
when you look at the architecture so
here is a our system you've got this red
network here which is your prediction
network sorry I swapped the colors on
you this is not metal learned this is
inner loop learned during like look
normal I get meta test training and then
this is meta learned here this
neuromodulatory network here and the
output of this layer is a multiplicative
weight on this layer here so it gets to
turn these neurons on and off depending
on whatever this network thinks about
that inputs tusks type so for some types
of net of neurons it might only let the
first 30% of the neurons fire etc etc
etc depending on the context and so if
you look at this what this allows you
the normal deep learning you have
if the forward pass goes through the
entire network so you have inference
everywhere and you also have learning
everywhere SGD goes back through the
whole network so you're going to get
this process of catastrophic forgetting
but with animal I don't know if I told
you the name but it's stands for a neuro
modulated meta learning algorithm which
is a play on both mammal and reptile
which we enjoyed so animal here neural
modulated meta learning algorithm it can
activate you can gate these activations
here and that means they can both select
it can cause selected activation so
these are not going to fire so it's kind
of taken the blue weights out of the
network
and then also then will effect the
backwards passive SGD so you get
selective plasticity all these purple
weights will not be modified because
they weren't involved in that forward
pass so you're giving more degrees of
freedom to the network so here is the
training domain here it's back to
Omniglot and each of the classes from
Omni law are going to be its own class
or task and so what we do here during
training is we're going to you know what
we'd normally ideally do is we would
differentiate through 600
tasks in a row which is like 9000 steps
of SGD you differentiate through that
entire thing back to the initial weight
vector and you'd be about your business
but that is hard Felipe has not figured
out how to do that 9000 steps of STV but
instead the oml paper came up with a
really cool innovation and that is this
particular loss function so what they do
is they say alright we're going to pick
one particular class the current task
and we're going to start doing SGD on
different instances of that class 20 of
them for example and then our meta loss
will be on both instances of that class
that we just saw so how good can you
remember what you saw and also other
classes from the training set and what
that means is that you have to learn the
thing you're just asked to train on
without messing up information from
other classes that you've learned in the
past but we're all going to do that I
like that a little tiny sample and then
we're gonna keep doing that over and
over again that obviates the need to
differentiate through 600 think classes
tasks directly so then we'll do that for
a different task and we'll repeat that
all those are the meta meta
optimizations cool and then what you can
do is your inner loop loss was always
with
those things and you can differentiate
all the way back to the initial
parameter vector so in mammal they did
it by choosing that exact same trick to
train the red and then they have inner
loop learning SGD normal STD on the blue
what we do is we use that meta learning
to train the red network the
neuromodulatory network which then masks
the activation of this thing which is
not met a train that's a normal
prediction network okay and then at meta
testing what we're gonna do is we're
gonna have a new class we do twenty
instances of that class and then I'm
sorry we do fifteen of that class and
then we check it on five more examples
of that particular class so the question
is both at the end of 15 steps here you
can ask how well did it memorize all of
these samples that's kind of like how
well did it fit the training set and
that's meta test training accuracy here
and then you can also ask how well does
it do on these other samples so how well
does it generalize to these unseen
samples that has never seen clear and so
you get that if you do it for at least
one task you get that plot there if you
do that for two tests then you can put a
plot there and there and then you can do
that across however many classes you
want to show the network and you can
stop and ask both how well did it do it
everything it saw in meta test training
and how well did it do I met a test
testing and you get these plots right so
then the question is you know how well
what we really care about is how well
does it do on the meta test test set all
right so I want to remind you that in
normal deep learning you have two things
helping you out you have iid training
and you have the fact that you typically
do multiple passes through the data
right multiple epochs in sequential
learning in this particular setup we are
going to not have ie D data so you have
to contend with catastrophic forgetting
and then we're only going to do one pass
through the data so it's also kind of
like a few shot learning problem and so
both of those forces are going to hurt
our performance so here's what the oml
paper showed if you look on meta test
training so how well did you memorize
the stuff that you were just shown even
after 150 classes you can see oml is
doing really really well and so is
animal but then we extended that all the
way up to 600 classes and now you see
this massive difference between oml and
animal but then we actually started
playing around with the oml a little bit
and what we realized is that if you
don't if you let it
only fine-tune I'm not gonna go back to
the picture but if you only fine-tune
the last of those two layers not just
the not both of them then you can do
much better that's this green thing here
and then the gap with animal is actually
pretty small now if you look at just
training from scratch you get this
terrible performance this is the
catastrophic forgetting problem we've
been dealing with in deep learning
forever and if you just pre trained on
the meta training set and then do
transfer learning you still fall off a
cliff so this is the normal catastrophic
forgetting in deep learning all right
now the real big difference is when you
look at meta test testing so how well
does that our generalize to new stuff
that it's seen
so during meta testing it's never going
to see anything that it saw in meta
training but it did see 15 of each of
600 classes and the question is how well
is to do with the five things of each of
those classes that it's never seen
before and what you see is that value
there's a massive gap between animal and
oml even the oml like the better version
at low ml as you go way out but kind of
maybe the big picture instead of
comparing between different methods it's
just like this is really cool like 600
classes in 9000 steps of SGD in and the
network is not forgetting terribly I
mean this is not as good at performance
as you might hope for but it's still
remembering a lot about what it learned
about these really early classes which
is pretty incredible
now in terms of what you might actually
be able to expect here we actually said
all right let's see if we can get rid of
catastrophic forgetting and see like
what's the best you could hope for so
the upper bound or Oracle for animal is
this red line here which is that you
just train iid instead of doing 600
classes in order you just train ieds
sampled from those 600 classes so you
eliminate catastrophic forgetting but
you still have one pass through the data
so you still have a low shell learning
problem and that's this red line here
and what you can see is that neural the
kind of animal is really close to that
Oracle there so to some extent the
problem is no longer catastrophic
forgetting it might be just data
efficiency sample efficient learning but
it's really not that they killers feel a
lot of a catastrophic forgetting is
what's harming us so that's really
exciting
the final thing I'll show in terms of
data from this / -
Keillor project is that it also like oml
it learns sparsity so here is the
activation of that blue network the for
the forward past non meddler Network
before it gets gated with the
neuromodulatory network this is the
output of the neuromodulatory network
and fifty percent of these neurons are
active for these individual example
samples and after a neuromodulatory
activation it's down to six percent so
its intelligently learning to figure out
how to figure out which small subset of
the network should be on in order to
learn without forgetting so any
questions I hope I'm not alright so to
conclude this section both o ml and
animal show the promise of meta learning
for learning solutions to catastrophic
forgetting and I would say more broadly
like whatever problem it is you're
trying to solve just set it up as a meta
learning problem and then see if the
meta learning can solve it for you
instead of trying to get to clever
animals advantage over ml also
underscores that even within the meta
learning paradigm which is what
everybody in this room is interested in
materials still matter you know should
you use neuromodulation should you use
heavy and learning should you use a
different architecture etc I think
there's lots of feature work that could
improve this even further including
trying to replace SGD entirely so animal
is still using SGD we're just modulating
it but you can imagine the version where
you just have like a giant and recurrent
neural net with differentiable
neuromodulation for example and the net
thing invents its own learning algorithm
that learns to learn without forgetting
that would be very exciting okay now we
get to some non meta learning stuff the
third pillar of AIGA z' is automatically
generating learning environments so all
of you know that in meta learning you
can't just train on a one environment
you have to train on a distribution of
environments so the question is where
will you get them you know how are you
going to provide the fuel to your meta
learning algorithm and if you pick some
are they going to be the right ones to
catalyze learning and I don't mean
learning on your particular problem
although that's interesting too but
we're about learning to get really far
to get to like really ambitious AI goals
how are we gonna do that we certainly
wouldn't want humans picking all of
those problems because we're probably
not good at it so in machine learning we
tend to do that though we pick the
challenges and then we go out and try to
solve them
but the question that I think is really
interesting to ask is can algorithms
invent their own problems while they're
trying to learn how to solve those
problems and so one thing that I find
really really inspirational are these
things called open-ended algorithms now
this is an algorithm that you turn it on
and you just let it run forever and it
continuously innovates forever it's just
like runs and runs and runs you know we
do not have any algorithms right now
that you would want to let run for like
I don't know more than a couple of years
a couple months but I'm talking about an
algorithm that could run for a billion
years
so could anybody in this room make an
algorithm that you would want to run for
a billion years and then come back and
check on it and it would still be doing
interesting stuff so we have seen an
example of that and that's on earth it's
a very simple algorithm of Darwinian
evolution plus a planet-sized computer
plus a planet a billion years later is
constantly innovating and doing really
really fascinating things so can we make
algorithms do this I think that is a
really fantastic and interesting
challenge and note you do not have to be
committed to using an evolution
algorithm to do that that's not at all
the point the point is it can be done
with you know whatever your favorite
optimization algorithm is we should be
able to make algorithms it endlessly
innovate now
evolution on earth and is not the only
algorithm that does this human culture
also does this we constantly are
innovating and making new new types of
novels and TV shows and science and art
and dance etc so what's one thing that's
kind of underlying all of these
open-ended algorithms is that they
invent their own challenges and solve
them and then the solution to those
challenges end up being new problems
that get solved so for example natural
selection invented the problem of leaves
high up in trees and then the solution
to that problem in the form of giraffes
and caterpillars right which are two
different ways to go eat those leaves
and then giraffes in turn are their own
problem that lions can prey upon and
hyenas etc so in this work we have this
new paper called poet which is a paired
open-ended trailblazer and I want to
highlight Ray Wang who is the done all
the heavy lifting on this project he's
done a wonderful job and the idea behind
this approach is that we want to try to
endlessly generate increasingly complex
and diverse
environments and their solutions all
together online in one big algorithm so
here's how it works we're gonna
periodically generate environments so to
do that that means we have to
parameterize environments you have to
have a way to search for environment so
you might have a parameter vector that
specifies a particular environment and
you know you can change those parameters
and you get different environments and
then what we're gonna do is we're gonna
add newly generated environments to the
population of environments if they're
not too easy for the current set of
agents and they're not too hard we're
also going to have a tiebreaker if
they're novelty to kind of like
incentivize these environments to go out
and be different and then that gives us
a population of environments and then
each one of those environments has an
agent that's paired in it and then once
we generates those new environments
we're going to start optimizing the
agents to solve those environments so
that's our paired that's where the
algorithm has paired yeah so there's a
paradox in life which is really I think
interesting which is that if you try too
hard to solve a problem you'll fail for
example if I put you in this maze here
and this year this robot and you try to
go to the this is the start and try to
go to the goal and your reward function
says only you know reduce your distance
to the goal then what you'll do is
you'll go up here and you'll bang your
head against this wall forever and
that's what this optimization algorithm
does which tries to reduce distance to
the goal if you just try to seek out and
go to new places in the maze or seek for
novelty you'll tribute solve this
problem which is what this maze does
over here now this is a more general
lesson in life for example it applies in
all of science and technology if you go
back a few hundred years to this
technology you see I want to heat up
food more rapidly you will never invent
the microwave if you only fund
researchers that put like that can heat
food faster because to invent the
microwave you have to have been working
on microwave technology too and produce
that innovation and notice that a
chocolate bar melted in your pocket
which is how the microwave was actually
invented and if you go back here a
couple millennia to abacuses and you say
oh that thing's cool it does computation
I want more computation and you only
fund people who will make you better you
know things that produce more compute
then you will never invent the modern
day computer because to produce this
so you have to have Ben go out working
on lightning and vacuum tubes which had
no immediate application for computation
whatsoever so the idea the idea is that
we call this goal switching let's skip
that example the idea is that if you're
optimizing for one thing like this row
the scientist here wants to optimize for
a robot that's walking but suddenly one
of your agents starts crawling will you
really well don't throw that out as a
failure instead capture that and start
optimizing for that too because that
might be an ultimately really good
stepping stone to walking same with
balancing on one foot now I do want to
mention one thing about poet I meant to
say this at the top poet so far is not a
meta learning system but it could be
used for meta learning so I'm gonna tell
you how to generate environments and
then that can be fuel for your meta
learning algorithms so this idea of goal
switching so you start optimizing your
agents on one goal if they suddenly they
start doing well on some other goal you
catch ants on the wing and you start
optimizing for that - that's called goal
switching and we've shown over and over
again in a lot of different papers that
this could really pay off because it
gets your agents off of local optima so
we in this paper that we had on the
cover of nature produced state of the
art adaptation in robots in this go
explore paper we use that to help solve
those two challenges that I talked about
and so the way that goal switching works
in poet is that you have this population
of different environments and
periodically you'll transfer an agent
from one environment to another
environment to see if it's doing better
okay so here's the particular domain and
the poet it's just an obstacle course
and this agents running through it tries
to run really fast without falling and
here are the degrees of freedom in the
environment the environment can make
environments that have different degrees
of say stump height or roughness in the
terrain and here's how it works so we
start with a parameter vector that
specifies an environment phi1 and then
we'll have a parameter vector that
specifies a theta that's paired with
that environment it will optimize theta
to perform well on phi and then what
we'll do is after theta is pretty good
at this will copy the environment to
make another environment phi - which is
a little bit different and then we'll do
transfer learning so we'll goal switch
this agent into this environment and
start optimizing it here now
optimization is in parallel both of
these things are kind of learning to
solve this problem together
then we might copy this environment that
might be too hard
we throw it out we generate a new
environment and we can test both of
these in this environment see which
one's better produce a new agent
optimize it there this does not have to
be a linear chain we can kind of produce
this environment maybe the best parent
for it is this and we go on and on now
imagine imagine that eventually we
produce is really really hard challenge
here and what you do is initially it
looks like this is the best
stepping-stone to see this population so
you start optimizing this in this and it
does okay but it's stuck on a local
Optima but we're doing goal switching in
this algorithm so this thing might
ultimately replace that thing and that
with a little bit more optimization on
this problem might ultimately produce
the best solution to that problem there
and ultimately we end up with this
solution to this problem which got us
off of these local optima so in this
particular case we have a three layer on
there all network it's being optimized
with evolution strategies but it could
be any our algorithm and here's some fun
videos of it working so you have this
little tiny robot here it's moving
through this terrain their environments
start off really simple and then over
time they the algorithm starts making
harder and harder versions of these
problems first it's kind of giving it
individual challenges like only little
stumps and only little gaps and only the
rough terrain over time it starts
producing like bigger gaps and it's
starting to combine things like you know
medium sized gaps and medium sized
stumps and eventually it kind of
produces these really hard environments
that have like gaps about as big as they
can do and it's using its lateral
sensors so they're kind of like tiny
jumps and it's really kind of pushing
the limits of what this body is capable
of here's another challenge that was
invented by poet all by itself which we
didn't even think was possible so one
interesting thing about poet is we found
is if you take the most challenging
environmental produces and you try to
directly optimize solutions in them it
doesn't work because there's no
curricula whereas poet is automatically
inventing its own curricula so what we
did is we took the hardest environments
here and we said we'll try to be more
fair and we'll create a direct path
curriculum which is a pretty common
technique so we take this parameter
vector for this environment this one
here and then we linearly interpolate or
along that parameter vector and we start
optimizing down it and it always fails
every single time because curricula are
hard designing them is hard and you
usually get it wrong
the harder the environment the more that
it failed so I wanted to show you this
one nice example here's a agent it's on
the most simple version of the problem
here and it's dragging it to me and what
you see is that ultimately the algorithm
creates a slightly harder version of the
problem this new dragging behavior no
longer works it trips the robot up and
so the robot stands up and gets a better
score and then worth further and then
basically eventually this thing was
better even when transferred back to
this simple environment so the algorithm
automatically goals switches this thing
back to the original we're now standing
up and it's performing better and there
were further optimization it gets a much
better score of 349 now we did the
counterfactual we went and ran this
agent in that environment for a long
time and it never stands up it's always
dragging its knee and so I think this
just exemplifies why curriculum learning
is hard because here you had to go and
work on a harder problem to get better
at the simple problem and get yourself
off of this local optimum so without if
you don't do go switching you know to
transfer you never solve these really
hard problems and you never generate
them so there's been a lot of work on
learning curricula I don't have time to
get into it all today but I just want to
quickly kind of fuel your intuitions
with future work we'd like to do this in
harder domains and you know you could
deal with multiple agents as well but I
think it's really thought-provoking to
put it in a world like this so if you
had enough compute to run poet in a
world like this where there are other
agents that you can barter with buy
goods from you fight with cooperate with
you can climb buildings deal with aerial
predators etc you could really imagine
meta learning some very sophisticated
behaviors in such a domain this is also
very related to open AI so currently
like I mentioned poet has not yet been
learned with meta learning each
environment is a little deterministic
environment you don't have to learn to
solve it but you could easily have all
of the tasks produced by poet as your
distribution that you train on or you
could have into each environment in poet
be its own little distribution that your
meta learning on and you still have goal
switching amongst the learners and this
is all very related open a eyes
automatic domain randomization if you
saw that paper which works really well
in solve the Rubik's Cube so I don't
have time to go through all of those
things but I think poets really exciting
because it deals with it invented some
curricula it hedges its bets it
endlessly innovates
it provides possibility for meta
learning and opens up a lot of really
interesting research directions but
mostly its inventing its own challenges
this is what we need for meta learning
so if you're interested in more on these
this subject related to poet and open
endedness you can watch our ICML
tutorial on population-based methods
which is at that link there
so with that I'll get to my last slide
thank you for your patience and that is
that I think that it's really fair in an
interesting to this question whether or
not the dominant paradigm and machine
learning of the manual approach to AI is
really going to get us ultimately to
where we want to go and I think that's
just kind of interesting to discuss and
I've proposed to you the idea of an
alternative paradigm which is the AI
generating algorithms paradigm where you
really go all-in on meta learning so
you're going to medal earn the
architecture the learning algorithms and
you're going to learn the environments
and generate them automatically and you
can imagine those three things coming
together to produce one really
interesting algorithm that potentially
could innovate forever and get us all
the way two extremely powerful forms of
AI and perhaps perhaps maybe human-level
AI and then I also introduced it for
each one of these pillars here some
pretty exotic new approaches that we've
been working on including generative
teaching networks differentiable hebbian
plasticity differentiable neural
modulated heavy and plasticity animal
and then poet which can automatically
generate environments so I hope that you
found that interesting and I want to say
thank you for your patience and for the
invitation
[Applause]
I also want to thank my collaborators
and there's at least a minute if anyone
has any high-level questions or
low-level questions yes yeah so I have a
lot of them in the paper the town
archives and so you can read a more
detailed thing there but I think that
the basically my view is that I'll give
you two answers one at a high level
Engineering is wonderful it's done
really impressive things you know we got
to the moon we got to Mars we built the
International Space Station we've built
Boeing's you know giant planes very
complicated machines and so you could
say that will keep kitai will continue
and we'll do we'll just build something
really big but I think it's fair to
question whether or not that will work
when the thing we're building requires
you know is just maybe you know maybe
we're not smart enough to do that you
know when it's requiring something
that's more sophisticated than something
we can understand so I think it's fair
to question that the second thing I
would say is that I think that the
manual path is making tremendous
progress and it's you know like all of
those stuff we've seen the last couple
years in AI has been from the manual
path from in most cases and so it's
really doing well and so the question is
I think eventually the AIGA path will
kind of be under it for a while and
underperform it and then it will cross
over and surpass it but I don't know
when that crossover point is the
crossover point itself might come after
we produce human-level AI and so that's
an argument that maybe both paths will
get there but maybe the the manual path
will get there faster yeah
between the work that your group does
and uber or self-driving thinking of
these thousands of edge cases the long
tail yeah so at the highest level I'm in
AI Labs which was formed after our
start-up geometric intelligence got
acquired and it was definitely set up to
be a basic research lab that was focused
on all areas of machine learning not
just self-driving and then in doober we
have an entirely separate organization
that focuses on self-driving so just
from an organizational perspective we
have totally different mandates which is
why you see here a lot of more basic
machine learning research that's not
just focused on that particular research
application but that said we find those
challenges interesting and we work on
them too and I can't comment too much
about internal applications of these
particular ideas to that but I can just
give you a flavor of how it might be
useful you could imagine for example in
poet that you're automatically inventing
as you mentioned long tail edge cases
that are very very difficult and are you
know hard for the current policy to
solve and then they may admit the
solution to those problems so that's
useful for a variety of ways one is
you're collecting hard heart you know
really hard corner cases that you can
add to your set to train on and to you
have the solution to those edge cases so
if your policy can consume you know
imitation learning or learning via
observation or demonstration then it can
use those individual solutions to then
distill back in to the main policy so
that's just kind of like one way that
these algorithms might be useful but
more broadly like the idea of open-ended
algorithms and getting off of local
optima better search techniques improved
memory usage more efficient learning
solving continual learning which is
definitely an issue with self-driving
and many business applications there's a
wide variety to apply there's a wide
opportunity to apply these sorts of
ideas within any company that has a lot
of challenging machine learning problems
which Oberer definitely has thank you
yes
really interesting to see how these
algorithms work in these kind of
simulated environments and stuff and I
was thinking we're doing robotics I was
thinking about how I could apply those
to what I do in robotics and say think
about it there's a lot of problems in
robotics that don't seem to be directly
addressed medicine so I was wondering if
you could comment on how we take these
to like a physical world where you can't
afford to fail we were still optimizing
the hardware we don't even know where so
yeah so one thing that I would say is I
recommend this paper here this paper
here what I love about it is that it
kind of marries the very expensive power
of stochastic optimization and deep
reinforcement learning or evolutionary
algorithms any of these stochastic
optimizers which are really expensive
and really sample inefficient but they
can be done in a simulation ahead of
time so it takes like stuff that you
learn in simulation and then it pours it
over in the real world to using that
information that you learn in simulation
and really really efficiently with
Bayesian optimization so don't have time
to tell you the full method but the idea
is that you can use a lot of the
algorithms that have talked about to
kind of explore the set of possibilities
learn a variety of different strategies
that are all really high performing like
a diverse set of high performing
strategies and then in the real world
when you only have a limited amount of
experiments you can do or time to learn
you can just switch between a whole
bunch of really good solutions
that's one flavor of answer a second
flavor of answer is the open AI robotics
cube strategy which is that you use
things like meta learning and poet to
train in simulation and then immediately
deploy in the real world and because the
open AI robotics q what it did was it
combined two of the three pillars from
AI GA s so it automatically generates an
increasingly large diverse set of
challenging environments to train on and
then it uses the AR l squared slash
learning the reinforcement learning
they're all networked that invents its
own learning algorithm and in simulation
that kept on waking up in a simulated
world that had a different like you know
like a different amount of gravity a
different of friction different mount
colors on the walls it's always in a
slightly
world and it has to rapidly figure out
like which world of my n what's the
friction what's the gravity quickly
solve the problem and it does that over
and over and over again in simulation a
great compute cost but then when you
drop it in the real world
the real world is just another new
challenge and it's like oh what's the
friction here and what's the weird
lighting effect here and what like how
do i flip the cube and then it can kind
of rapidly and be a sample efficient
learner that solves the rubik's cube and
that's what they show that it did so you
could harness compute ahead of time to
learn to learn efficiently and then just
deploy that in the world so I think
those are two different techniques both
of which if you can be used to great
effect in robotics and Chelsea's done a
lot of great work showing that that
works and so Sergei and so other people
in the field and I open AI and so I
don't think that it's the case the
robotics has to wait for AI to get
better and more sample efficient I think
that now you can already start taking
advantage of these techniques and open
AI I think is the best showcase of that
there was one more back there I don't
know when you have to call it though
okay we'll take the one more question
that was back there
yeah
we have talked about that I think that's
a fascinating direction I'm not familiar
with that particular challenge at in
their house but just the idea of like
poet plus minecraft I think is really
great because it's such an open-ended
world to be really fascinating to see
what it does yeah thank you all again I
appreciate it
[Applause]